invite everyone to if they want to ask a
question to let me know uh we will have
statements from the ministers followed
by questions i'm told that they have
until two o'clock so if everyone can
keep questions and answers and
statements short we'll get as much
territory covered as possible
if those those in the room raise your
hand this could be like the national
press leader because and i'm explaining
that simply because this is a for the
largest number of people i think we've
had in months if not for a couple of
years in person covering the press
conference so uh in room raise your hand
if you are on zoom uh use the raised
hand function and uh you will be able to
join the queue ministers
okay
so uh thank you uh elizabeth
good afternoon today i'm joined by my
colleagues the minister of transport
omar al gabra
the minister of health genevieve duklow
and the president of the treasury board
monafactier
our top priority continues to be the
health and safety
of all canadians
and our commitment to work together with
provinces and territories to keep
canadians safe
remains unchanged
as the warmer weather arrives
we know that across the country
canadians are looking forward to seeing
friends and family
and enjoying the outdoors
what they needed to do to protect
today's announcement is possible because
canadians have stepped up
to protect each other
we are now able to adjust our policy
because we have followed consistently
the best advice
from public health authorities
but we need to make sure we are ready
for the fall
and our best protection against covet 19
is being properly vaccinated
if you haven't gotten your vaccines or
your booster yet
i encourage you to do so
i know that canadians may wonder
is this too fast
or is this too slow
it has been
very tough
for canadians these past two years
our job as a national government has
always been
to keep canadians safe
if the situation
takes a turn for the worse
we are prepared to bring back
the policies necessary
to protect canadians
we don't regret it all
being cautious when it comes to a virus
that has tragically killed
tens of thousands of canadians
and millions of people around the world
acting prudently has saved lives and we
will always continue
to be cautious
cautiously yeah
this announcement is not about
shortening
wait times that are currently being
experienced
at some of canada's airports
as you know these wait times are mainly
caused
by staffing shortages
the adjustments we're making today
are based on science
and they will not have an impact
immediately
on these airport delays
we remain committed to reducing
the wait times at canada's airport
we have already taken
a number of steps to improve the
situation
and my colleague the transport minister
will have more to say
in the coming moments
thanks to canadians we are able to make
today's announcement
and to share what precise next steps are
to come
i'd like to invite my colleague the
minister of transport to say a few words
omar
thank you dominic
hello everyone bonjour tooth
covert 19 and its threat to our public
health and our economy has caused
governments around the world and in
canada to take extraordinary measures to
protect their citizens
our government has made a solemn
commitment to canadians to be prudent
and focus on doing the right thing
guided by science and expert advice
our approach to protecting canadians has
worked
canada has one of the highest
vaccination rates in the world with one
of the lowest death rates in the world
and is also experiencing one of the
fastest economic recoveries
we've seen how our measures have slowed
down several covet peaks and has given
our health care system early warnings to
adjust and respond
as the kovitz situation evolves and as
we learn more about this virus we have
been adjusting our measures
many of these measures have been lifted
and it's clear that the covid situation
is not the same now as it was last fall
when we implemented the vaccine mandate
for travelers and transport workers
situations
since last fall and
this is the and that and this is thanks
to the millions of canadians who rolled
up their sleeves and got vaccinated
that's why today's announcement is
possible
and i'm pleased to announce that on june
20th our government will suspend the
requirement to be vaccinated in order to
board a plane or train in canada
the
in canada
employers in the federally regulated
transportation sector will also no
longer need to have vaccination
requirement for their employees
the suspension of the vaccine mandate
was informed by key indicators including
the epidemiological situation and
modeling
vaccine science and high levels of
vaccination against covet 19 in canada
as for travelers coming to canada by air
land and marine there are no changes
in canada entering canada all travelers
entering canada must continue to follow
all entry requirements including
vaccination and using a rive can
as for cruise ships vaccination for
passengers and crew will remain in place
this decision is based on the unique
nature of cruise ship travel including
the fact that passengers are in close
contact with each other for extended
periods of time
also
travelers on federally regulated planes
and trains still need to wear a mask
planes and trains masks are an effective
way of reducing
transmission especially in areas with
restricted space
such as onboard planes trains or cruise
ships
a government will always continue to
evaluate measures and will not hesitate
to make additional adjustments based on
the latest public health advice and
science
it's also important to note that while
travelers will be able to board a plane
without having to verify their
vaccination status
international travelers need to verify
public health requirements imposed by
the country they want to visit
many countries around the world
including the u.s continue to require a
proof of vaccination upon entering their
country
i want to thank all the travelers who've
been vaccinated to protect themselves
and others as well as the transport
workers who are working tirelessly to
ensure the recovery of the sector
thank you everyone merci and now i'd
like to give the floor to minister
fortier
thank you merci minister al gabra
james
including the rcmp as the employer of
the federal public service the
government has a responsibility to
ensure public service servants can work
safely
and the policy has done what it was
meant to do it helped make federal work
sites as well as the communities where
public servants live and work safer
and it provided a safer environment for
canadians accessing government services
in person including for more vulnerable
members of our communities
public servants understand the
importance of keeping themselves and
others safe which is why close to 99 of
them stepped up and got vaccinated
public service first servants were not
alone in rolling up their sleeves
um
[Music]
uh
is
as of that date employees of the core
public administration including the rcmp
will no longer be required to be
vaccinated against coven 19 as a
condition of employment
employees who are on administrative
leave without pay as a result of the
vaccination policy will be contacted by
their managers to resume regular duties
with pay and the bargaining agents have
been informed
similarly we expect other vaccine
requirements put in place for employees
of separate agencies
crown corporations
governor and council appointments and
contractors to also be suspended
and i want to reiterate that vaccines
continue to provide strong protection
against serious illness all canadians
should keep their vaccinations up to
date to keep that protection as high as
possible
canada
remains essential to protect not only
our own health but our health care
system and our economy
again this means keeping up to date with
our vaccinations and it also means being
ready to adjust our approach
risk
to closely monitor domestic and
international scientific evidence to
access the need for appropriate public
health measures including
a reintroduction of vaccine mandates if
necessary
our greatest priority thank
foreign
recognizing the enormous strides we have
made since the beginning of this
pandemic
our government's response has always
been informed by evolving science
research prudence and expert public
health advice to help make decisions
that serve to protect people everywhere
in canada
following a successful vaccination
campaign supported by proactive
vaccine procurements and collaboration
at all levels of government
32 million eligible people in canada
have now received a primary series of
vaccinations against corgi 19.
and every day
about the virus
foreign
is
low vaccination remains absolutely
essential the omicron variant has shown
us that two doses are no longer enough
because the immunity acquired through
two doses varies and wanes over time
in this context it is therefore
essential that all canadians understand
the importance of following the
recommendations of public health
authorities and stay up to date with
their vaccination
in simple terms this means that if you
are eligible for a third or even a
fourth dose under the recommendations of
public health officials you should
receive it as soon as possible
this is the best way to avoid developing
a serious form of kobe 19
being hospitalized or dying from it
it's also the best way to reduce the
spread of corvid 19 and the incidence of
long covid it's also the best way to
protect our health care workers and the
most vulnerable among us
as mentioned by my colleagues after
reviewing the latest scientific evidence
evolving kobit 19 epidemiology globally
and in canada
vaccination coverage rates and listening
to the advice of public health officials
and experts we have decided to suspend
mandatory vaccinations for domestic
travelers transportation workers and
federal employees
the context has changed in that we now
benefit from better levels of immunity
from both vaccination and infection
the wider availability of anti-viral
drugs
and more and decreasing hospitalization
rates
canada is now better equipped to
effectively manage the covet 19 pandemic
and reduce pressure on our healthcare
workers
as i have said because of the immense
value of maintaining individual and
collective immunity both in terms of
protecting our health care system and
our economy
the government of canada recommends that
everyone in canada continue to protect
themselves and their loved ones by
staying up to date with corvid 19
vaccines which includes a third dose for
all adults
while the suspension of vaccine mandates
reflects an improved public health
situation in canada the corvit-19 virus
continues to evolve rapidly and
circulate in canada and globally
given this context current vaccination
requirements and other measures at the
border entry will remain in effect to
reduce the potential impact of
international travel on our health care
system and workers and track the
potential introduction of new variants
of concern
as the covet 19 situation evolves and
our country prepares itself for whatever
may come our way later and in the fall
we will continue to evaluate new
evidence to determine the best way to
reduce the burden of corbyn 19 in our
communities and protect our healthcare
workers and patients
is
vaccination combined with individual
public health measures continues to be
the best way to protect ourselves our
loved ones and our economy as we return
to the activities and social
interactions we have so dearly missed
over the past two years merci thank you
thank you very much mister uh we will
now go to questions everyone gets one
question one follow-up if everyone can
try to keep the questions and the
answers short because we only have 15 or
18 minutes left out of the time we are
told that you have to leave for question
period so
and the more people know the more the
the better the reporting uh first
question
is
foreign
with other public health
is it just going to stay forever
um let me take a step at this question
and first let me talk about masks again
as minister duklowa said the evidence is
clear
that mask is an effective layer of
protection and given how
a minor inconvenience it is and the
benefit that it poses to not only the
passengers but the people sitting next
to them thinking of vulnerable
individuals immune compromise i think
it's a small minor inconvenience to ask
of travelers who are sitting together in
a small tight enclosed place
uh about arrived can a rifecan is a tool
as i stated in my remarks we are
maintaining a vaccine requirement for
international travelers who are arriving
to canada and arrive can is a very
helpful tool
to ensure that travelers arriving
travelers have the required vaccination
certificate
we are working with cbsa with public
health agency or canada to ensure
that we increase
awareness about our ifcan
that we increase uh compliance with the
rive can that will reduce
numbers of questions that are asked to
streamline so we're working on
efficiencies to ensure that arrived can
is less of of
of a source of complaint however it
continues to be a meaningful tool to
verify the vaccination status of
travelers who are arriving into our
borders
david cochran cbc
uh first question is for minister
fortier this is a suspension of the
vaccine requirement for uh public sector
workers so you say the ones who have
been suspended without pay will be
allowed to come back to work
but should covet conditions worsen in
the fall and you have to bring back the
vaccine mandate for the public service
could they go through an unpaid
suspension all over again if there's no
change in their status
well first thank you for your question
and
as you know um
public servants that did not attest to
having vaccination with that were leave
without pay
currently they will be able to come back
to work as we are suspending if we go
back in the fall or at some point with
these the mandates we will go back to uh
the policy that we had
in place i think that is something we
have to
make sure
to
focus on the fact that
public servants stepped up in this
current
vaccine mandate up to or close to 99
percent of the public servants attested
having both vaccines and we have to
commend public service of uh stepping up
for that thank you
a follow-up question from mr algara
what does this mean for cross-border
truckers who certainly made their views
on all of this
well known earlier this year does this
in any way affect the status of the
people who occupied the downtown of the
city corps
david let me be clear as i've been
trying to clarify this for canadians
throughout this is that truckers have
actually also stepped up
the vast majority of truckers have
gotten vaccinated and we saw that ever
since the introduction of vaccine
mandate at the border that our trucking
volume at the border uh not only was it
not impacted but we've been seeing
increases what that tells me is that
truckers have stepped up and done their
part to protect themselves their
families and uh and the sector
and we're also seeing
an equivalent
measure at the u.s border so we know
that this is a reciprocal
uh a measure that the u.s expects of
truckers who are crossing the borders
and canada has the same reciprocal
measures it is it continues to be an
important
tool to ensure uh that we protect canada
against uh importation as the virus
having said that we will
constantly assess
uh our measures as we've demonstrated in
the past but i'll tell you truckers are
stepping up they've provide continued to
provide service for canadians and
deliver the products that canadians need
kevin carmichael ctv
sorry uh kevin gallagher here with ctv
um my apologies this is the second time
i've done this so i i you're very
forgiving no problem um
i think i want to move on right away to
um right now if more canadians who are
unvaccinated can now travel
in airports like pearson that are
already clogged what's the plan
to deal with the expected increase in
travel of unvaccinated canadians
uh
kevin um
the issue at airports is an important
issue for our government we have been
acting and working collaboratively with
airports with airlines to ensure that we
have
increased efficiencies at our airports
we're seeing as you've heard me say this
before and and the facts prove that
point similar phenomena at airports
around the world because we're seeing
surge in demand
that uh that the capacities of airport
are
struggling to keep up with having said
that we have put a lot of measures in
place we've increased resources of
cancer significantly cbsa we've
suspended uh and are going to be lifting
random testing at airports off airports
we've
streamlined some processes including
arrivecan as i mentioned earlier
we are regularly speaking to airlines
and airports and by the way airlines are
struggling as well with fi with the
resources we continue to encourage them
to
do as much as they can just like the
government is doing we're adding
resources we're seeing airports need to
add more resources but there is a plan
measures have been in place and regular
discussions on a daily basis are taking
place to ensure and and the data by the
way proves that the last couple of weeks
we're seeing significant improvements in
delay data whether for outbound travel
or inbound travelers but i know we need
to do more
is there specific
data that you can mention that leads to
today's decision why is the
hospitalization rates covert rates and
other data that you've looked at to make
this decision today what's different
about
today and june 20th that could not have
been done a month ago
uh i mean i'll ask minister duklow as
well uh uh
to add his own comments but i'll tell
you
this decision today took
a lot of discussions and consultations
so
the decision today is not based on
something that we woke up yesterday or
this morning and decided to do we take
we've done our homework this is what
canadians expect us to do they've seen
us focus on their health and safety and
that every time we've put in place a
measure or lifted a measure it's done
guided by science with the aim of
protecting the health and safety of
canadians so what got us today was a
period of discussions of consultations
of looking at the big picture of
preparing ourselves for a potential wave
in the fall but the current situation
today so we had to look at all the
options and all the data that we have
and after a thoughtful deliberate
prudent discussions we've reached this
decision so it's it's what canadians
expect us to do we will always err on
the side of public health and safety
i would add that the the key word today
is transition
and dr stam spoke to that just last
friday she spoke clearly about the need
to transition
we've been we've done extremely well in
canada until now
we have as we all know we've had a very
large two dose rate in canada which has
led to
one of the lowest death rates in the
world of which we can be very proud
obviously that comes with
lower numbers of hospitalizations
smaller economic costs than we would
have had otherwise dr tam also
signaled that in the five first months
of this year we have had as many deaths
and hospitalizations as in the entire
year of 2021.
so that decision
took the time it needed to be taken so
that we could keep protecting the health
and safety of canadians kobe 19 is still
with us
fortunately in the last few weeks as we
were hoping the epidemiology has
improved the number of hospitalizations
cases and deaths has fallen and experts
tell us that we should expect the next
few weeks in the summer time for obvious
reasons to be
relatively uh good in terms of covet 19
like the last two summers have been also
a bit better than than than around the
two summers
what we also know from dr tan and every
other expert on corvin 19 is that
although two doses of steel still
protects significantly well against
severe disease and death two doses are
not enough now to protect against
infection and transmission and that is
why we are transitioning now to
an up-to-date vaccination
definition of what it means to be
adequately protected against corvid 19.
fully protected with two doses
doesn't work anymore dr tam said that
last friday it's now up-to-date
vaccination that needs to be used when
you talk about what canadians should do
which we should expect of canadians and
what this government should be expected
to do in the future as we do that we are
going to take advantage of the next few
weeks and months to work closely with
provinces and territories to increase
significantly our rate of third doses
our rate of boosters in canada is too
low
it's lower than all other g7 countries
and that is not good
however we know we can do better and we
have done really well with two doses
over the last two a year and a half and
that's we're going that's what we're
going to do also in the next weeks and
months with all provinces and
territories so that we are better
prepared and sufficiently prepared for
what as minister gabra said may be
coming in the fall
okay now i'm told that the ministers
will be able to stay with us a few more
minutes than originally uh forecast and
now if i can get this right uh ryan
tumulty national post
yeah i'm wondering you just talked about
the ineffectiveness of of two doses uh
versus the omicron did you consider as
part of these discussions uh creating a
mandate for three doses instead of
suspending the mandates
we have considered all options and we'll
keep considering all options as we keep
protecting the health and safety of
canadians that's what they ask of us
that's what we'll keep doing
and and according to what public health
experts have told us internally and as
you heard dr tam say publicly on friday
we now need to transition in the
transition to an up-to-date status which
for most adults means a third dose there
are
approximately 60
of adults in canada that have a third
dose we need to move that up
significantly at least to what we have
had for the last few months in terms of
second doses about 90 percent of
canadians have had a second dose and
that's a great outcome of which we can
collectively be very proud so it's a
type of
of of objectives and ambitions that we
can set
collectively as dr tam says
as said that on friday that is needed
now with the science that has evolved
and with the epidemiology that is now
making it possible today to make those
announcements and prepare for
a strong vaccination campaign with the
full input and obviously collaboration
of provinces and territories
yeah and mr minister al grabber you've
said today that you're going to keep
arrive can and the vaccination
requirement for international travels
heard from a lot of people that say that
is one of the major bottlenecks at
airports because the cba has cbsa has to
check vaccine credentials from all over
the world in all sorts of different
formats can you explain given that that
it's a significant barrier why you feel
keeping that is so essential
first of all it is important to continue
to require a proof of vaccination from
international travelers
it is
again vaccine even a two dose vaccine
continues to protect against severity of
illness and in order for us to continue
to protect
the demands on our public health care
system we want to make sure that
incoming travelers are at minimum
vaccinated
second arrive can is a tool that public
health and cbsa
are utilizing to verify and ensure that
incoming travelers have the the proof of
vaccinations required
third are there ways for us to improve
how
the processes at airports to verify
proof of vaccination absolutely and as i
stated earlier we are working with
airlines to ensure
higher uh
arrived can compliance uh by ensuring
that airlines inform
their passengers prior to boarding on
the plane better we're actually we
looked at the data we saw which airlines
needed more help to ensure the better
compliance and we're working with those
airlines we're working with airports to
ensure that there's better compliance
once the passenger arrives we're working
with cbsa to minimize the number of
questions that are duplicative for
example and we don't have to ask these
questions so we're looking at uh and we
have implemented many measures to ease
potential bottlenecks but i want to
close with saying by saying this other
point that i've said on many occasions
international airports are facing
similar challenges
heathrow's airport amsterdam airports
dublin's airports us airports this is a
phenomena that we're seeing because of
the surge in demand and the
the the labor is trying to catch up to
that surge and we're not saying that to
accept the current situation we are
acting we have a responsibility to act
we're working with airlines we're
working with airports and we're doing
everything we can to ease those
bottlenecks
valeri
canada
does that mean it'll be three doses
i'm sure
is
[Music]
of an up-to-date vaccinations
is
uh
[Music]
is
oh
this is
these excuses
hi um
mr al gabra i'm not sure i understand
though you've talked about the work
you've done till now working to ease
chaos at airports but
you're essentially allowing about seven
million more canadians and their
families to travel now so what exactly
is the federal government doing to ease
the potential lineups and chaos that
could cause
so tanda first of all we'd be happy to
provide you with data over the last two
weeks and how we're seeing significant
improvements over the last two weeks of
the flow of passengers either outbound
or inbound um
and including inbound there's at least
40 reduction of hold
uh from
this week compared to last week
having said that let me go through some
of the measures that we've been doing to
ease
some of the congestions that we're
witnessing at airports
we've hired 900 today by the way the
number is almost 900 kata staff and
that's in a span of few weeks
if you
understand labor shortages that we're
facing today you know what a big feat
that's been 900 workers katsa has
have been added to our staff and been
now we're seeing a lot of improvement as
well as outbound travels um uh we
we are streamlining um arrivals
processes so uh we i talked about arrive
can we're increasing compliance we're
increasing kiosks at cbsa uh cbsa is
also hiring a lot of summer students
so there's a lot more resources right
now available and improved processes for
receiving international travelers
there's daily meetings particularly at
pearson airport that brings together
cbsa transport canada katsa
public health and airlines where they're
discussing every day the current
schedules the current potential
bottlenecks and taking action on the
spot to ease these uh these pressures
pressures so i want to say that it is
yes it is an international phenomena but
our government is acting urgently
swiftly and decisively to provide the
support to airlines to to airports we
are now calling as well on airports and
and airlines to do everything they can
to continue to work with us on ensuring
that we smooth in these potential
bottlenecks so there's been a lot of
measures and we're seeing through data
we're seeing improvements over the last
few weeks
um minister duklow
can you tell me when exactly did dr tam
and the public health agency first
advise you that the government could
relax
these restrictions
and since you've said that the third
dose basically being two dosed is not
enough third dose is
uh the decision not to
change that formal definition of what it
is to be fully vaccinated i'm not sure i
understand why you don't actually change
that now as opposed to wait until fall
or some other time
okay let me be and i should let dr tama
obviously
speak for herself but dr tam
didn't advise
us to drop a particular measure in
particular as openly she said on pub in
on friday she said that two doses don't
work anymore when it comes to protecting
against infection and transmission
doesn't work enough obviously it's
better than zero dollars but not enough
compared to what
a
delta situation would have generated
and she also pointed to the fact that
the issue is the winning immunity if you
get the two dollars
the second dose now you'll be protected
the range of between 40 and 80
against infection plus an additional
protection against transmission
but that wanes over time so after six to
seven months it's around 20 or lower
when it comes to protection against
infection and transmission and that's
not enough either what she also said on
friday
and she has mentioned that a couple of
times earlier that if you get a third
dose then that
jumps up
back to between 40 and 80 percent again
it also increases your protection
against severe disease which is also a
key indicator because we've had two dose
after a few months unfortunately your
protection against severe disease falls
to approximately 60 to 70 percent but if
you get a third dose it it goes up to 90
which is a big impact
it effectively reduces by two-thirds
your risk of being hospitalized when you
have a third dose as opposed to a second
dose so she said all of those things
very clearly on friday but she had
mentioned those things earlier as well
obviously she communicated those facts
with us
over time now we are meeting very
regularly at least once a week i do that
obviously more often than that
to get the latest scientific evidence
from her team and from experts outside
of the government
why wait to do that to change the
definition
why which question sorry the question
was
since you're saying third doses are the
be all end all right now or at least the
current
answer but you're not changing any
definitions around what it means to be
fully vaxxed so i'm not understanding
that so what is clear now
and what the public health experts
including outside of the government have
been saying for some time and that's
also true for many of them outside of
canada i may come back to that in a
moment i don't want to spend too much
time but what has been said for many
weeks and months if you read through the
media and expert reports you'll see that
it's been increasingly clear that the
governor of canada should
state clearly
that a inappropriate
inappropriate understanding of
vaccination must be up-to-date
vaccinations people should be up to date
vaccinated
fully vaccinated according to health
experts including to dr tom and pinhac
that's not um
strong enough now so we need to to
transition to a new phase of fighting a
kobe 19 that comes with the
right the strong recommendation that
nasi made some weeks ago already that
people should be fully should be up to
date in their vaccination service
okay abigail binman at global
minister al gabra your government has
been consistently vague about specific
benchmarks that would be needed to reach
today's decision i i've heard a number
of answers that give some general uh
indicators but i'm wondering what
specifically what specific benchmarks
got you here and again what benchmarks
could we see in the fall that would
cause you to to bring these mandates
back
uh so i mean i
we've been clear about the uh benchmarks
that got us to this point uh first and
foremost uh the current situation kovitz
situation at home um we are we are
seeing improvement at our public health
care system we're seeing declining of
of covet rates
and we have one of the highest
vaccination rates in the world uh um we
have data now that says at a two dose uh
is uh is not
doing what given omicron is not doing
what it did last fall
so there's been several indicators
that we've relied on to get to this
decision
and this these indicators were examined
in our conversations about what the next
steps are so
these indicators informed our
discussions but we needed
to look at what next
so what given these indicators what is
our policy moving forward what is our
approach moving forward and that's why
we have we are offering now a
comprehensive plan yes we're adjusting
our measures based as we have done in
the past uh i can go through a list of
measures by the way that we've lifted
over the last months whether it's
pre-departure tests whether it's upon
arrival test whether it's hotel
quarantine uh uh
whether it's uh all kinds of other uh uh
measures that have been lifted or
adjusted and we're doing today the same
thing we're adjusting based on improving
or changing circumstances but we are
offering a vision for
uh to assure to
comfort canadians that we have we will
continue to be vigilant if circumstances
change we will react and we will be uh
proactive in ensuring that we continue
to protect the health and safety of
kidneys
but your point about offering a vision
to comfort canadians is sort of exactly
what i'm talking about here you're
talking about lower cases but you know
is it x percent of hospital beds that
aren't full you talk about high
vaccination rates that needle hasn't
really moved recently is it a specific
point like what can canadians take as
you know a hard statistic that helps
them understand why they're gone today
not last month and when they may come
back
i mean again i'll ask mr duklow to add
his own comments but i'll tell you
while it's we're always always looking
for quantitative benchmarks and
quantitative benchmarks are helpful but
there are also qualitative benchmarks
that we look at including risk and risk
factors so those risk factors are a
qualitative assessment based on the
current situation not only of the nature
of the virus not only on the nature of
the transmission of the virus but also
what other risks risks are we
contemplating that's why it's very hard
to just give
a hard quantitative benchmarks without
leaving room for a qualitative
assessment of the current situation and
we know that the current situation is
going to change hopefully to the better
but we need to be prepared if it changes
to the worst and and yes all of these
factors abigail you mentioned are part
of these examinations but there are
other risk factors that we have to take
into account in cooperation and and and
and discussions with our partners at the
provinces and the territories and
perhaps just if i can add something
abigail i think what my colleagues have
said and what we've said from the
beginning
is that we have deliberately
and consciously chosen to take a
cautious approach
some other people have advocated more
reckless courses of action
some people are looking for those magic
numbers as omar said where all of a
sudden it goes away
but as jaive said there are also some
stark numbers that tell us that kovid
has not gone away
so we are as a national government i
talk to provincial and territorial
governments all the time jave duclos has
meetings with his colleagues
across the country we're constantly
evaluating our posture and seeing what
we can do to ensure the best series of
measures to protect canadians and as
omar said they have evolved over time as
the virus has evolved so today is simply
a continuation of a measured cautious
approach that we hope will allow
canadians as the nice weather comes as
the summer months come
to perhaps be in a different posture but
we're not naive about what might happen
in the fall we hope very much that that
is not the reality but as we've said if
we get to a different circumstance in
the fall or this winter we will again
not hesitate to take our
responsibilities and to put in place a
series of measures necessary to protect
canadians and i think that's a
fundamental difference from some of our
political adversaries and i think it's a
fundamental difference that canadians
have come to respect and appreciate
okay we've got about three minutes left
and four people left on the list uh
unless the ministers are able to stay a
couple minutes later mia robson canadian
press
so
you've uh you've said repeatedly that
science is what was informing your
decisions but you have six months ago
the sign said that two doses wasn't
enough six months ago the science said
that the the vaccines that we had were
not preventing infection why did it take
six months for your government to move
on vaccine mandates
well
let me say two things a
we've been very successful until now and
i think it's important for canadians to
be proud of what they've done
b we know and we've all been told by dr
tom and many other experts that we need
to transition and that's what we're
doing we're transitioning because we
want to continue being success
successful and to continue being
successful
means that we need to transition to a
third dose slash up-to-date vaccination
status for
most canadians and that's what we're
going to do in the next few weeks and
months as we work for provinces and
territories because obviously they have
many more levers to work with than we do
at the federal level
that doesn't answer the question though
as to why it took six months when the
science told you six months ago that the
two doses wasn't enough and many of your
opponents have accused you of playing
politics with this rather than science
you have not put the science on the
table what science has changed in the
last few weeks that's different than
what we knew in december
that made you decide that now is the
time to change this well one thing
hasn't changed and one thing is changing
the thing has that hasn't changed is
what experts have told us for many weeks
now is that then what canadians
understand and most of them understand
and have followed their advice is that
we need three doses to protect against
infection transmission severe disease
long covered hospitalization and death
what is changing now
is our focus in the next few weeks and
months to increase our rate of
collective protection against kobe 19
through
a significant effort in vaccinating
canadians with more boosters so we will
do that because we know the summer time
is it isn't is a season where as
minister leblanc said now would be a
warmer
temperature the if we if we i listen to
experts and base our understanding on
base on on what we've seen in the last
two years there will be lower cases
fewer cases fewer hospitalizations
that's the right time for canadians to
not only to pause and deserve a summer
of break but also to think of how to
better be prepared individually and
collectively for the fall season
but again if
people are always looking for a magic
date and a magic number and if covid has
taught us one thing there is no magic
date where everything's suddenly
resolved and every
public health measure can disappear and
as my colleagues have said
the numbers that we're focused on are
the numbers of canadians that are in
hospital today including intensive care
units
uh with covet 19 and the number of
people who've tragically died in canada
and around the world because of covet so
if our political adversaries say that
there's some
political circumstance i think frankly
that would be the height of hypocrisy
when our government has been prepared to
take the difficult decisions including
taking the time necessary to arrive at
the right cautious approach
we haven't been reckless as some of our
political adversaries have in terms of
making up scientific evidence or
pointing to a whole series of factors
that they say offers simplistic
solutions we have as a government and
omar said it very well deliberately
taken the time necessary to arrive at
the right place based on the best
medical and scientific advice that we
can have in canada and from partners
around the world and that's exactly what
we're going to continue to do so we've
done it for over two years since covet
began and we're going to continue to do
it so people shouldn't be surprised by
that and people shouldn't be surprised
that we're not taking knee-jerk
positions simply because some political
adversary pretends there's a magic
solution
okay we're at the time that we were
given there are three people still on
the list is there any
possibility that you might be able to
take one or two more questions maybe
three
we're a lot less rowdy
okay well thank you very much uh and
this ends this press conference
[Music]